This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. By all accounts, if you've ever taken a bus two or from Tel Aviv's new central bus station, you've never forgotten the experience. It's one of the most bizarre and magical and disgusting and enchanting places you can imagine. This is Mishiharman of the Radio Show and podcast Israel Story, talking about the unforgettable ramshackle, massive bus station known as the city under Aruf. It's dirty and smelly and feels depressing, deserted, but at the same time it's colorful and full of life.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。毋庸置疑，如果你曾坐过往返特拉维夫新中央车站的公交车，你一定不会忘记那种体验。这是你能想象到的最光怪陆离、神奇美妙、恶心至极又迷人至极的地方之一。这是广播节目和播客《以色列故事》的主持人米希·哈尔曼，在谈论那个被称为“屋顶下的城市”的、令人难忘、破败不堪且庞大无比的公交车站。这里又脏又臭，透着压抑和荒凉，但与此同时，它又五彩斑斓，充满了生机。
The station houses vendors, foreign workers and refugees from all over the world. Philippi Host, I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. Turn the corner, an old timer might drag you into the Netsach David synagogue, after which you can meander past tattoo parlors, churches, the free STD clinic, or train brides getting their hair braided, the Israeli Filipino matchmaking agency, fringe theater spaces, and end up at a giant Yiddish book library. For about 20 years until the year 2010, Tel Aviv's new central bus station was the largest in the world.
车站里汇聚了来自世界各地的摊贩、外籍劳工和难民。菲利皮·霍斯特：“我很好。我很好。我很好。我很好。”拐过街角，一位老者可能会把你拉进内扎赫·大卫犹太会堂，之后你可以在纹身店、教堂、免费性病诊所闲逛，或者看新娘们在编头发、看以色列-菲律宾红娘机构、边缘剧场空间，最后来到一个巨大的意第绪语藏书馆。在大约 20 年的时间里，直到 2010 年，特拉维夫的新中央车站都是世界上最大的公交车站。
This is in a city whose population just barely reached 400,000 people during this time. The bus station is dizzying. In fact, it's almost impossible not to get lost there. All attempts at designing proper wayfinding have failed miserably. But what's probably most interesting about the new central bus station in Tel Aviv is that it's sort of a layered fossil of the history of Israel. If archaeologists were to excavate through the layers they'd find remnants of every phase in the short story of this state. From independence through post-war euphoria to recession and westernization,
而这还是在一个当时人口刚勉强达到 40 万的城市里。这个公交车站令人眼花缭乱。事实上，在那里几乎不可能不迷路。所有设计合适导视系统的尝试都以惨败告终。但特拉维夫新中央车站最有趣的地方，可能在于它就像是 اسرائیل（以色列）历史的一块分层化石。如果考古学家发掘这些地层，他们会找到这个国家短暂历史中每个阶段的遗迹。从独立到战后狂热，再到经济衰退和西方化，
they'd be able to trace the waves of immigration to Israel from Europe and North Africa. So in many ways the story of Tel Aviv's new central bus station is the story of Israel. And this story of Israel as told through this bus station is going to be told to us by a high metal from the brilliant radio program Israel story. ‫היא פרקרם ‫היא איזוייסטורי. ‫שום דבר אני לא אמרת ההנה. ‫שום דבר לא שווה. ‫היא איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איזו איז in Tel Aviv's new central bus station in the early 90s, even before it opened. He dreamt of eventually passing it on to his children. I bought it as an investment 20 years ago.
他们将能够追溯以色列来自欧洲和北非的移民潮。所以在很多情况下，特拉维夫新中央车站的故事就是以色列的故事。而通过这个公交车站讲述的以色列故事，将由来自精彩广播节目《以色列故事》的高个子金属乐队（注：音译/双关误读，原文为 high metal，此处疑指某人名或特定称呼）为我们讲述。在 20 世纪 90 年代初特拉维夫新中央车站开业前，他就梦想着最终把它传给自己的孩子。“我 20 年前把它作为投资买下来。
Now I'm stuck here. No matter what happens, I'm stuck. Pain taxes, utility bills, office fees, all suck me, call a tahana, this place ruined me. Elon's store has been closed for years because no one hangs out anymore at the far end of the fourth floor, where a huge supermarket used to stand. And Ilan is just one of hundreds of vendors who paid good money to purchase the store
现在我被困在这里了。不管发生什么，我都卡在这了。痛苦的税收、水电费、办公室杂费，全都榨干我，打个电话给塔哈纳（车站），这个地方把我毁了。”伊兰的店铺已经关门多年，因为再也没有人在第四层的远端闲逛了，而那里过去曾是一家巨大的超市。伊兰只是数百名花了大价钱购买这里店铺的摊贩之一，
here and who are today stuck with a property that's worth absolutely nothing. I met Ilan in a section of the station called the Ramlod Market on the third floor. He was moonlighting, selling baby clothes to aro train refugees at a friend's stall. Trying to make up for the lost income from his out of business shop. Most of the stalls around him are abandoned. Old newspapers are glued to the display windows of nearby storefronts. If you come close, you can make out headlines about the 2003 Columbia Space Shuttle disaster or the disengagement from Gaza in 2005. The ceilings are covered with black sot.
而如今他们却被困在一个一文不值的房产里。我在车站三层一个叫拉姆罗德市场的地方遇到了伊兰。他在一家朋友的摊位兼职，向阿罗特兰难民出售婴儿用品，以此来弥补店铺倒闭带来的收入损失。他周围的大多数摊位都荒废了。旧报纸被贴在附近店面的展示窗上。走近点，你还能辨认出关于 2003 年哥伦比亚号航天飞机灾难或 2005 年加沙撤离行动的头条新闻。天花板上覆满黑色的煤烟。
Board peddlers anxiously smoke cigarettes right underneath from the old sign that says no smoking. And the smell of nicotine blends into the stench of urine, sweat and diesel fuse. What can I say? It's depressing to hang out with the vendors of the Tachhanamir Kazitakhadashah. Tel Aviv's new central bus station. The structure itself is terribly confusing and that's no coincidence. It was designed to make people get lost.
小贩们焦虑地抽着烟，烟头就在写着“禁止吸烟”的旧标牌下方，尼古丁的气味与尿液、汗水和柴油废气的恶臭混合在一起。我能说什么呢？和塔哈纳米尔·卡齐塔哈达沙（特拉维夫新中央车站）的小贩们混在一起，真是让人心情低落。建筑本身极其令人困惑，这并非巧合。它的设计就是为了让人迷路。
The labyrinth, it was coined by the station's chief architect, Ram Karmie. And in a labyrinth, you get lost. You know how you get in, but you have no idea how you get out. Or even if you get out. רמקרמי. ולמרנט, שאתה נתקל. תתקל, שאתה נתקל, אבל שאתה נתקל, שאתה נתקל, או כמו שאתה נתקל. תקל, שאתה נתקל. אני אמרת, ואני אעשה את רמקרמי.
“迷宫”，这是车站总设计师拉姆·卡米创造的概念。而在迷宫里，你就会迷路。你知道你怎么进去的，但你完全不知道怎么出来。甚至不知道你能不能出来。想象一下，把中央车站当成一座屋顶下的城市。所以既然它是一座屋顶下的城市，为什么我们在里面迷一点路也不行呢？因此，为了帮我以一种、我不知道，稍微更有条理的方式迷路，我找了一对充满活力的建筑师组合。嗨，我是塔莉亚·维迪。
רמתה שאתה נתקל, שאתה נתקל, שאתה נתקל. ואני אמרת, שאתה נתקל, שאתה נתקל, שאתה נתקל, שאתה נתקל, שאתה נתקל, שאתה נתקל, שאתה נתקל. imagine the central bastation as a city under a roof. So if it is a city under a roof, why shouldn't we get a little bit lost inside? So in order to help me get lost in and I don't know, slightly more organized fashion, I teamed up with an energetic architectural duo. Hi, I'm Talia, the Vidi.
我的名字叫阿拉德·霍恩。我是来自以色列的建筑师。我也是一名以色列建筑师。我目前是伦敦建筑联盟学院的硕士生。我刚从哈佛设计研究生院毕业，多年来我一直和塔莉亚一起调查和研究特拉维夫的中央车站。对中央车站的整个研究始于我们不得不重新整理拉姆·卡米的档案，在翻阅大量布满灰尘的文件和设计图时，我们发现
My name is Alad that horn. I'm an architect from Israel. I'm an Israeli architect as well. And I'm currently a master student at the Architectural Association in London. I just graduated from master's school of design in Harvard and I've been investigating, researching the central bus station in Tel Aviv with Talia for many years now. The whole research of the central bus station started when we had to reorganize Ramkar MIS archive and while going through loads of dusty documents and plans we found
了来自 60 年代和 70 年代关于中央车站的惊人资料。在此之前我们对车站就很熟悉，我们也知道大家对车站的看法以及这座建筑有多复杂。但随后我们看到了这些图纸，它们其实真的非常漂亮。这些图纸确实很漂亮，有着流畅的线条和巨大的玻璃天窗。但很少有人在现今耸立的这座建筑中看到多少美感。塔莉亚和阿拉德是个例外。如果不迷失在这些奇怪黑暗的小巷里，你真的很难描述它，在那里你周围真的空无一人。几乎有一半在街面以下，所以它是黑暗的，实际上非常黑暗而且闷不透气。某种程度上它就像一个黑暗游乐园。一方面你其实感到害怕，另一方面
amazing materials dated from the 60s and 70s about the central bus station. We we knew the station pretty well even before and we knew what everybody thinks about the station and how complicated the building is. But then we saw these drawings and they were like really beautiful actually. The drawings are indeed beautiful, they're sweeping lines and huge glass skylights. But few people see much beauty in the building as it stands today. Talia and Elad are exceptions. It's really hard to describe it without getting lost in these weird dark alleys where you really don't have anybody around you. Almost half of it is underneath the street level, so it is dark, really dark actually and airless. In a way it's like a dark amusement park. You're actually afraid on one hand and on the other
又有着最令人兴奋的环境围绕着你，有来自世界各地的面孔，超级绚丽多彩。我会说这是一个多感官的地方。它几乎允许任何事情或所有事情在其中发生。我们问自己的最大问题是，到底哪里出了问题。所以我们去那里试图找到答案。他们带着我参观了他们这个神奇、多感官、黑暗的游乐园。在某个时刻，他们把我领到废弃的一层，然后顺着一条狭窄的坡道穿过一扇嘎吱作响的侧门，我环顾四周，意识到我们正身处一个荒废电影院的大厅。所以我们实际上在地下 15 米深处，在这个曾被称为“大电影院”的地方。
hands having like the most exciting environment around you with people from all around the world, super colorful. I would say it's a multi-central place. It allows almost anything or everything to happen in it. The biggest question that we asked ourselves is what ran wrong actually. So we go there and try to find the answer for that. They took me around this magical, multisensual, dark amusement park of theirs. At some point they led me down to the abandoned first floor. Then up a narrow ramp and through a creaky side door, I looked around and realized we were in the lobby of a deserted movie theater. So we're actually 15 meters below ground level here in what was the Grand Cinema.
这里曾有六家电影院，名字非常棒，比如约翰·韦恩、珠穆朗玛峰、甘地。尽管距离在这里上映的最后一部电影滚动字幕已经过去 15 年多，但影院的状况依然很好。墙上贴满了诸如《低俗小说》和《泰坦尼克号》等电影的海报。这里的音响效果依然极佳，红色天鹅绒座椅的垫子也相当舒服。
There were six movie theaters here with amazing names like John Wayne Everest, Gandhi. Even though it's been more than 15 years since the credits rolled on the last movie played here, the theaters are still in great shape. The walls are covered with posters of films like pop fiction and Titanic. The acoustics remain excellent, and the cushions of the red velvet seats are still pretty comfy.
这种被遗忘的魅力见证了这座车站早期所承载的巨大希望。规划者的最初设想是，乘客在等车时可以顺便进来看看电影。但那从未发生，影院开业短短几年后就倒闭了。正如你所看到的，今天它已经完全被废弃了。是的，就是这样。时间在这里静止了。让我们看看，时间在这里静止了。新中央车站于 1993 年夏天向公众敞开大门。经过近三十年的规划，它崭新、闪亮且令人兴奋。
This forgotten glamour is testimony to the big hopes the station embodied in its early days. The planner's original idea was that passengers would pop in and catch a movie as they waited for the bus. But that never happened, and the cinema closed down just a few years after it opened. Today as you can see, it's completely abandoned. Yep, that's it. Time stood still here. Let's see, time stood still here. The new central bus station opened its doors to the public in the summer of 1993. After nearly three decades of planning, it was shiny and new and exciting.
但随后在短短几年内，它就成了镇上最阴暗的地方。那么，一个地方怎么能在这么短的时间内，从如此辉煌沦落到如此荒废呢？沙兰·罗斯巴尔斯。我是一名建筑师、作家、出版商和老师，就住在车站附近。300 米。事情是这样的，为了回答这个问题，我们需要一直追溯到 1948 年以色列建国之前的日子。我们应该谈谈这块土地，中央车站就是建在雅法阿拉伯人的土地上，
But then in just a few short years, it became the griniest place in town. So how does a place go from such splendor to such neglect in so short a period? Sharan Rothbals. I am an architect, writer, publisher and teacher who lives right near the station. 300 meters. Things that in order to answer this question, we need to go all the way back to the days before the establishment of Israel in 1948. the days before the establishment of Israel in 1948. We should talk about the land, the central bastation was built on, and Islam belonged to Arabs from Java,
这里曾是一个橘园。平哈斯·阿布拉莫夫就是在那个橘园的边缘长大的。你还记得很清楚吗？当然。它被称为阿布拉莫夫橘园。我们常常溜进栅栏底下，偷几个橘子，然后逃跑。
it used to be an orange grove. Pinchas Abramov grew up on the outskirts of that grove. You remember it well? Aya Shama Yapar deshle Abid. Of course. It was called Abid's Grove. We used to sneak in underneath the fence, steal some oranges, and then run away.
独立战争后，雅法和特拉维夫之间的这些柑橘园大多被抛弃、砍伐、荒废、没收，这取决于你的政治观点。无论如何，国家接管了这片土地，犹太人开始搬进来。平哈斯的家就坐落在今天新中央车站所在地。
Following the war of independence, most of these citrus groves in the area between Jaffa and Tel Aviv were abandoned, slashed, deserted, slashed, confiscated, depending on your political point of view. In any event, the state took over the land and Jews started moving in. Pinchas' homes stood exactly where the new central bus station is situated today.
我的房子是一座特殊的房子，就在罗文斯基街的拐角处，转角过去的第二栋房子。二楼有一面大墙，画着加利利海的壁画，上面有一个渔夫在钓鱼。真是了不得。多么漂亮的房子。真是一栋好房子。
A bite, Chile, a bite, mew, hug. My house was a special house right in the corner of Lovinsky Street, the second house from the corner. On the second floor, there was this big wall, chatt a mural of the sea of Galilee, with a fisherman fishing. Zaya Masha, Loma Olama, was really something. Pai Tepefe, beautiful house. What a house.
最初，政府想要扩建一个名为内维沙纳的附近街区，但和往常一样，计划被一拖再拖、停滞不前，直到最后被完全遗忘。因此，这里没有诞生崭新的住宅区，反而开始发展出一种贫民窟。一个由帐篷、棚屋和仓库组成的贫民窟。与此同时，在镇上较好的地段，住着一个叫阿盖·皮尔茨的人。他是在 30 年代从波兰来的移民，在特拉维夫的海滨开了一家名叫“皮尔茨咖啡馆”的著名咖啡店。
Masha. Initially, the government wanted to expand a nearby neighborhood by the name of Nevishanan, but as always the plans were delayed and installed until they were forgotten altogether. So instead of a brand new residential neighborhood, a favela of sorts started to develop there. A slum of tents, sheds, and warehouses. Meanwhile, in a better part of town, lived a man called Arge Pils. He was an immigrant coming from Poland in the 30s and he opened up Cafe Pils, which was a really famous coffee shop on the seaside of Tel Aviv.
皮尔茨咖啡馆是城中最时髦的去处。英国高级军官们来这里喝着干马提尼放松身心。身穿燕尾服、打着领结的优雅侍者四处走动，供应着红酒炖鸡和牛排，背景里管弦乐队演奏着最新的流行金曲。当他在咖啡馆里消磨时光、抽着雪茄时，皮尔茨无法不注意到周围正在进行的建设热潮。特拉维夫现在正焕发着勃勃生机。这是一部 50 年代末的宣传片。每天有 10 万人来到我们镇。
Cafe Pils was the swankiest joint in town. Senior British officers came to relax over dry martinis. Elegant waiters in long tails in a bowtie would walk around serving cockovans, steak grenades, and in orchestra played the latest hits in the background. And as he spent his days sitting in his cafe, smoking his cigars, Peelts couldn't help notice the construction friends he's going on all around it. Pellet Viva's bursting with life by now. This is a promotional film from the late 50s. We 100,000 people arrive in our town every day.
尽管耶路撒冷是我们的首都，但特拉维夫是工业中心。我曾经看过一张纽约的照片，嗯，特拉维夫几乎一样。当然，除了我们还没有摩天大楼这一点之外。特拉维夫一片繁荣，而皮尔茨这位不知疲倦的企业家，到处都能发现房地产商机。于是他从犹太国民基金会买下了这个由旧橘园变成的贫民窟。但随后又遇到了像平哈斯这样的擅自占地者的麻烦。皮尔茨出现并想把我们赶走。他逐渐把他们全部买断，开进拖拉机，推平了棚屋，创造了一块巨大的土地。
Although Jerusalem is our capital, Pellet Viva is the center of industry. Once I saw a picture of New York, well, Tel Aviv is almost the same. Apart from the fact, of course, that we haven't got skyscrapers yet. Tel Aviv was humming, and PILTS, a tireless entrepreneur, spotted real estate opportunities everywhere. So he purchased the old orange grove, turned slum from the Jewish National Fund. But then there was the problem of the squatters, like pinjas. Pilzigia, Pilz showed up and wanted us out. Gratually he bought them all out, brought in tractors and raised the sheds to create one giant plot of land.
这个地理位置堪称理想。街对面就是内维沙纳，一个人口稠密、低收入的街区。而在内维沙纳的正中间，坐落着特拉维夫的主要公交车站——老中央车站。每天都有数十辆公交车在街区狭窄的街道上之字形穿梭，正如经常发生的那样，这导致该地区堕落为一个犯罪和贫困的中心。市政规划者很清楚，有些地方出了问题。他们想把车站搬到另一个地方，同时翻新并开放旧车站。所以皮尔茨这个相当聪明的人直接找到市政府对他们说，等一下，你们为什么要搬走车站然后再搬回来呢？就让它留在原地吧。嗯，我会给你们
The location was an ideal. Across the street was Nevisha Nanah, a densely populated, low-income neighborhood. And in the middle of Nevisha Nanah stood Tel Aviv's main bus station, the old central bus station. Every day dozens and dozens of buses zigzag through the neighborhoods narrow streets and as often happens this contributed to the areas decline into a hub of crime and poverty. It was clear to the municipal planners that something wasn't working. They wanted to move the station to another place while they renovate and open up the old one. So PILTS who was a really clever guy just came up to the municipality and told them, wait a minute, why would you move the bastation and then bring it back? Just keep it where it is. Well, I will build
建一个新的。皮尔茨有着宏大的梦想。他打算通过将新车站打造成一个巨大购物中心的一部分来为其建设融资。当它被构思时，它本意要成为世界上最大的公交车站。以色列当时仍然是一个小国，人口刚超过 200 万。所以你可以想象，许多人认为这个想法简直荒谬绝伦。但皮尔茨很有个人魅力，更重要的是，他认识所有对的人。所以他成功说服了市政厅的人，并在他们的批准下，他接触了一位 33 岁的年轻建筑师拉姆·卡米。皮尔茨对他说：“拉米，给我建个中央车站。”
you a new one. And PILTS had big dreams. He was going to finance the building of the new bastation by making it part of a huge mall. It was meant to be the largest bus station in the world when it was conceived. Israel was still a small country, with a population of just over 2 million. So as you might imagine, lots of people thought the idea was absolutely insane. But Pilswitz was charismatic, and even more importantly, he knew all the right people. So he managed to persuade the folks at City Hall and with their approval he approached a 33 year old architect Ram Karmie. And Pilt said to him, Rami, build me a central bus station. Karmie's first proposal was relatively simple.
卡米的第一个提案相对简单。这个想法是，车站的底层将类似于火车站，公交车可以直接穿行而过。在此之上，他们将建造公寓、住宅、办公室，而在中心将有一个大公园，实际上就坐落在车站的屋顶上。从那以后，事情就开始走下坡路了。卡米的计划很快就出现了问题。埃加德和丹这两家在该项目中成为利益相关者的竞争对手公交公司，在意识到他们必须共用一层楼时愤怒不已。
The idea was that the station's lower level would be similar to a train station in the sense that the buses would pass right through it. On top of that, they would build apartments, hotels, offices and in the center there would be a big park which would actually sit on the station's roof. From there on it only went downhill. Pretty quickly issues arose with Karmie's plan. Eggad and Dan, the two rival bus companies who had become stakeholders in the project, were furious when they realized they would have to share a floor.
“没问题，”开发商说，“我们把公交公司放在不同的楼层。”卡米有个绝妙的主意，将交通流量分配在一楼和六楼之间。丹公司的公交车停在一楼，而埃加德的城际公交车则从最顶上六楼的站台出发。因此，从一个转到另一个的乘客必须穿过整栋建筑，并会在商场的商店里花掉真金白银。是的，这在当时看起来很符合逻辑。建造巨型建筑和超级建筑的想法
Not a problem, said the developers. We'll put the bus companies on separate levels. Karmie had a brilliant idea, dividing the transportation between the first and the sixth floor. The Dan City buses would stop on the first floor, and Egghead's intercity buses would leave from a platform all the way up on the sixth floor. So passengers transferring from one to the other would have to go through the entire building and would spend good money in malls shops. Yeah, it seemed logical at this time. The idea of building a huge structure and mega structure
在当时非常流行。而我来了，把这个想法带给了以色列。与此同时，皮尔茨明白这个项目的花费将远超他最初的预期。于是他说：“拉米，我们需要更多可以出售的空间。”因此，在卡米提交的每一个后续设计中，车站都变得越来越大。到了 1967 年 11 月提交的第六版草案时，
was very trendy at the time. And I'm coming and putting this idea to Israel. Pills in the meantime understood that the project was going to be much more expensive than he'd originally expected. So he said, Rami, we need more spaces which we can sell. And so in every subsequent design, Karmie submitted. The station grew bigger and bigger. By the sixth draft handed in in November 1967,
蓝图已经开始类似于我们今天所知的这个庞然大物。事实上，我记得阿米特在谈论中央车站时说，他们想建造世界上最大的中央车站。他们一直想知道，为什么会有人想在一个这么小的国家建造最大的中央车站。但事实就是如此。最后，新中央车站的设计包括八层，总面积达到 23 万平方米或 57 英亩，这大致相当于两栋帝国大厦加在一起。就在皮尔茨拿到建筑许可证的时候，
the blueprint had started to resemble the behemoth we know today. In fact, I remember Amit talking about the central bastation and saying that they wanted to build the largest bastation in the world. And they kept wondering why would anyone want to build a largest central bastation in such a small country. But this is exactly what happened. In the end, the new central bastation was designed to include eight floors for a total of 230 square meters or 57 acres, which is more or less two Empire State buildings together. By the time Pillscotal is building permits in
世界各地的建筑风格开始发生变化。新的共识认为，几个小规模的公共交通枢纽比一个巨大的车站更有效率，此外，已经有足够的例子得出结论：巨型建筑很少能按其最初的意图发挥作用，有足够的例子得出结论：巨型建筑很少能按其最初的意图发挥作用。最重要的是，皮尔茨还有其他麻烦。他买下了所有非法占地者，但邻近街道的居民却怒火中烧。尽管他们的街区从来都不是特别好或高端的高档住宅区，但他们担心新车站和所有增加的公交车流量会使他们公寓的价值进一步贬值。
order, architectural styles around the world had begun to change. New wisdom had it that a few small-scale public transportation hubs were more efficient than one gigantic station, and besides there were enough examples to conclude that megastructures rarely functioned the, there were enough examples to conclude that megastructures rarely functioned the way they were originally intended to. On top of all that, Pills had other problems. He had bought out all the squatters, but the residents in the adjacent streets were a livid. Even though their neighborhood had never been particularly nice or upscale, they were concerned that the new station and all the increased bus traffic would depreciate the value of their apartments even more.
他们最终将生活在烟雾和废气之中。事实证明，他们是对的。这是该街区的居民舒拉·凯谢特。你能想象在一声声可怕、刺耳的噪音中醒来是什么感觉吗？我醒来，而这噪音停不下来。你坐在家里，想看电视却听不见。你想和家人说话。你没法说话。这是一种震耳欲聋的噪音。
That they would end up living in a cloud of smoke and fumes. And as it turns out, they were right. This is Shula Keshet, a resident of the neighborhood. Can you imagine what it feels like to wake up to this terrifying, redling noise. And I wake up and this noise doesn't stop. You sit at home, you want to watch TV and you can't hear it. You want to talk with the family. You can't talk. It's a deafening noise.
除此之外，我们不得不关上阳台，因为从公交车上经过的人几乎可以看到我们房子里面发生的事情。我不知道我能不能听到，但我真的听不到。太可怕了。我能对你说什么？我听不见。我听不见。可怕的噪音，无时无刻。那是辛查·纳西，他仍然住在其中一个公交车出口的正对面。
Besides that, we have to shut the balconies because the people who go by in the buses can practically see what's going on inside our houses. I don't know if I can't hear it, but I can't hear it. It's awful. What can I tell you? I can't hear it. I can't hear it. Charable noise, all the time. That's Simchanasi, who still lives directly across from one of the bus exits
他是向皮尔茨抱怨的居民之一，嗯，你可以自行判断。这是一段他在晚上 10 点从客厅窗户录下的录音。不，不，不，不，不。中央车站一开始就根本不应该建造。新中央车站一开始就根本不应该建造。绝对不该。但皮尔茨决心已定。1967 年 12 月 14 日，在以色列在六日战争中国土扩大三倍的六个月后，交通部长、特拉维夫市长以及许多其他政要聚集在旧橘园的边缘，为卡米的杰作奠基。
He was one of the residents who complained to Pils and well you can judge for yourself This is a recording from his living room window at 10 p.m No, no, no, no, no No central bus station should never have been built during the first place A new central bus station should never have been built during the first place. Absolutely not. But Pils was determined, and on December 14, 1967, six months after Israel tripled its size in the six-day war, the Minister of Transportation, the Mayor of Tel Aviv, and many other dignitaries, gathered at the edge of the Old Orange Grove and laid down the
当时感觉这是一个巨大的国家，一个巨大的车站似乎很合时宜。建造世界最大公交车站的狂妄自大，符合战后普遍的狂热情绪。在随后的几个月里，数百名工人挖掘地基、铺设钢筋、浇筑混凝土、钻孔和锤击，而与此同时居民们在外面示威。与此同时，皮尔茨准备进入他计划的第二阶段。他需要出售他正在建造的大片商业空间。于是他邀请来自世界各地的犹太人来参观这个地方，并享受他资助的以色列免费旅游，有点像伯特莱特之前的伯特莱特（注：美国犹太人组织赴以旅游项目 Birthright Israel）。当然，这趟行程的压轴戏将是参观新中央车站——皮尔茨的新项目，期望游客们能在车站里买下一家店铺。
cornerstone for amys' creation. It now felt like a huge country, a huge station seemed fitting. The hubris of building the world's largest bus station was in line with the general sense of post-war euphoria. In the months that followed, hundreds of workers dug foundations, laid rebar, poured in concrete, drilled and hammered, and all the while residents demonstrated outside. Peelts in the meantime was ready to move on to the second stage of his plan. He needed to sell the vast commercial space he was building. So he invited Jews from all over the world to come on and see the place and get a free
皮尔茨希望利用六日战争后溢出的犹太复国主义情绪。令人惊叹的是，他成功了。数百人买下了店铺。其中一些人贷款购买，而另一些人，比如来自法国的马克·阿尔莫格，卖掉了房子并完成了阿利亚（移居以色列）。
tour in Israel on him, sort of like Perthrite before Perthrite. And of course the grand finale of the trip would be a visit to the new central bus station, Pills' new project with the expectations that the visitors would buy a shop in the station. Peel's hope to tap into the overflowing Zionist sentiments that followed the six day war. And amazingly, he succeeded. Hundreds of people bought shops. Some of them took out loans. And others, like Mark Almog from France, sold their houses and made a liat.
我们被许诺在这样一个让全世界引以为傲的购物中心里拥有一家宏伟的店铺。其他人，比如平哈斯，他那幅画有加利利海画作的房子为了给车站让路而被拆除，作为某种补偿分到了店铺。我在中央车站分到了 42 平方米。他们说这家店将是了不得的东西，了不得的好东西。必须记住的是，皮尔茨并没有像今天的购物中心开发商那样出租这些店铺。他是作为房产出售的。业主将资产登记在自己名下，就像买公寓一样。
We were promised a magnificent shop in a shopping center that the whole world would take pride in. Others, like Pinchas, whose house with the painting of the Sea of Galilee was demolished, to make way for the station, were given shops as some sort of compensation. I got 42 meters at the central bus station. They said this shop will be something, something great. It's important to bear in mind that PILT did not lease those shops as a mall developer wood today. He sold them as property. The owners registered the asset under their own names, just like buying an apartment.
在接下来的六年里，随着皮尔茨在图纸上卖出越来越多的店铺，这座宏伟的建筑开始成形。人们对此感到兴奋。每隔几个月，报纸上就会出现这样的头条：“屋顶下的城市正在复活”或“世界上最高科技的公交车站即将开业”。但随后在 1973 年，赎罪日战争爆发了，随之而来的是全国性的经济衰退。吉卡尔·罗文斯基，皮尔茨为建造和资助该项目而成立的承包公司开始动摇。
Over the next six years as PILT sold more and more of his stores on paper, the massive building started taking shape. People were excited about it. Every few months there would be a headline in the papers saying something like, a city under a roof is coming to life, or the world's most high-tech bus station due to open. But then in 1973 came the Yom Kippel War War and with it a general nationwide recession. Kikarlivinsky, the contracting company, Pilsit set up to build and bankroll the project started faltering.
混凝土短缺、工会问题以及日益增加的债务接踵而至。最终，在 1976 年，皮尔茨申请破产，建设完全停工。到那时，这座建筑大部分已经建成，成了市中心的一具巨大的混凝土骨架。蒂勒的爷爷奶奶都还记得这个地方是该市的巨大白象（累赘）。现在，关于谁应该为这场惨败负责的骂战爆发了。公共委员会成立了，但指责游戏一直在继续，因此在长达 12 年的时间里，皮尔茨自称的这个悲惨车站一直闲置着。或者几乎闲置。
There was a shortage of concrete, problems with the workers unions and growing debt. Finally, in 1976, Pils filed for bankruptcy and the construction stopped altogether. By that time, the structure was already mostly built, a huge concrete skeleton in the middle of the city. Tillers grandma and grandpa all remember this place as the city's big white elephant. Now a saga of who should take responsibility for the fiasco erupted. Public commissions were established, but the blame game went on and so for 12 years, the miserable station has peeled some self-called it remained empty. Or almost empty.
一大群蝙蝠把这座建筑当作了它们的家。渐渐地，它开始容纳社会边缘的那类群体。到了 80 年代初，该车站已经获得了其臭名昭著的声誉。它成了地下聚会点。大型锐舞派对以及摇滚和重金属音乐会在这里举行。
A huge colony of bats made the building their home. Gradually it started to host those sorts of marginal parts of society. Sam Ligel Sam not so much. By the early 80s the station had already gained its notorious reputation. It served as an underground meeting point. Huge raves and rock and metal concerts to placement. Ah! Seba bachurok balay lahat gil malahat gil malahat gil malahat gil Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey Director Moldech Ayona bought the project from its creditors for a bargain price of $5 million. Once again you could hear the hustle and bustle of construction work in the empty concrete shell.
导演莫迪凯·约纳以 500 万美元的跳楼价从债权人手中买下了这个项目。你又可以在这座空荡荡的混凝土空壳里听到建筑施工的喧嚣了。约纳和他的前任皮尔茨一样，认识对的人，比如当时的交通部长摩西·卡察夫。当卡察夫在车站预计向公众开放前几个月访问该工地时，他说：“我当然感到惊喜。我们当然会很高兴以任何方式帮助你们克服官僚主义障碍。”
Ayona, like his predecessor, peels, knew the right people, like the then minister of transportation, Moshikatsav. When Katsav visited the site just a few months before it was supposed to open to the public, he said, I am certainly pleasantly surprised. And we, of course, will be happy to help you in any way to overcome bureaucratic obstacles. What Katzav was happy about was that Yona was delivering. The station was set to open more or less on schedule.
卡察夫高兴的是约纳在兑现承诺。车站将或多或少按计划开业。大部分房地产在皮尔茨时期就已经售出。因此，为了在财务上可行，约纳不得不建造更多、更多、更多的东西。这个巨大的车站，就像那只极度饥饿的毛毛虫一样，不断生长。车站的总建筑面积是授权面积的两倍多。数万平方米是违章建筑，没有建筑许可证甚至没有规划图。
Most of the real estate had already been sold back in the PILT stays. So in order to make this financially viable, Yona had to build more and more and more. The huge station, like the very hungry caterpillar, just grew and grew. The total build-up area in the station is more than double the area that was authorized. מה למקפול ממש ימותר לבנות? תותו, בלתיים, במהר, זה שצייקים, שצייקים, שצייקים, שצייקים, שצייקים, שצייקים. זה שצוו. לואיירה רואה מפהלוווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווווו that tens of thousands of square meters that were built illegally without building permits or even organized plans. And they were also sold to people. And there's really nothing to do about that.
它们也被卖给了人们。对此真的无能为力。所以你的意思是说，新中央车站是这座城市最大的违章建筑？在全国都是。然而，卡察夫承诺消除官僚主义障碍，他兑现了诺言。广告宣传册和电台活动敦促公众购买店铺。他们说，全国最大的商业中心正在路上。别让它在没有你的情况下开业。而且，那些似乎已经忘记了车站第一世带来的心痛的人们，又一次排队向约纳购买店铺。
So what you're saying is that the new central bus station is the largest construction violation in the city. Baratz? In the country. Katzav, however, promised to remove bureaucratic obstacles, and he kept his word. Advertising brochures and radio campaigns urged the public to buy a shop. The country's biggest commercial center is on its way, they said. Don't let it start without you. And again, people who seemed to have forgotten the heartache of the station's first incarnation lined up to buy a store from Yona.
1993 年夏天，在雄心勃勃的建筑师拉姆·卡米动笔画图 29 年后，所有寻常的政要再次在车站聚首。时任总理伊扎克·拉宾出席了仪式，交通部长、财政部长、特拉维夫市长以及卡米本人也出席了，这是他唯一一次在建筑运营期间参观该建筑。在一次罕见的自嘲幽默中，开幕式通过释放一个呈白象形状的巨型氦气球拉开帷幕。但并不是所有人都觉得好笑。
In the summer of 1993, 29 years after the ambitious architect Ram Karmie put pencil to paper, all the usual dignitaries reconvened at the station. Prime Minister Yitzhak Rabing was there, as was the transportation minister, the finance minister, the mayor of Tel Aviv, and even Karmie himself, in what was the only time he ever visited the building while it was working. In a rare moment of self-deprecating humor, the opening ceremony was kicked off by releasing a giant helium balloon in a shape of a white elephant. But not everyone was amused.
这里又是舒拉·凯谢特，车站闷闷不乐的邻居之一。当时他们在里面庆祝，而我们在外面举行大型示威。这基本上被忽视了，而全以色列都在当晚的全国电视上听到了盛大开幕的消息。在皮尔茨看中这块地皮 30 多年后，特拉维夫的新中央车站终于投入运营。它从那时起一直开放至今，但它远非原本设想的高档购物中心。有一种诱惑，把头几年视为事情还在运转的时期。但说实话，这里的事情从来没有真正运转过。约纳从未设法卖掉他建造的所有新店铺，因此许多店铺一直空置，
Here again is Shula Keshet, one of the station's unhappy neighbors. At the time they were celebrating inside, we were standing outside in a big demonstration ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה עוד כבר, ‫הוא נעשה was largely ignored, while all of Israel heard about the grand opening that evening on National TV. More than 30 years after PILT said his eyes on the plot, the new central bus station in Tel Aviv was now up and running. It's been open ever since, but it's far from the posh shopping mall it was meant to be. There's a certain temptation to view those first years as the years when things were still working. But honestly, things never really worked here. Yona never managed to sell all the new stores he had built, so many of them stood vacant,
而许多开业的店铺，特别是位于这个庞大迷宫遥远角落的店铺，几乎没有什么人流量。你可以理解为什么小贩们对这个地方没有什么好话可说。这里的车站，不好工作。他们什么时候把这地方烧掉？这里什么都没有。这里有更好的地方吗？这里什么都没有。没有空调。什么都没有。全是这些。
and many of the ones that were open, especially stores located in the far corners of this vast labyrinth, were barely getting any foot traffic. You can understand why the vendors don't have many good words to say about this place. This in Tachana, not good working. When did they get a burn this place? Mesh, there's nothing here. Bit gore diuter rana shimiya. There's more place? There's nothing here. There's no aircon. Nothing. It's things.
看看我的收银机。没钱。过来看看。你在这里谋生不了，没工作，没别的。我只是坐在这里消磨时间。比起特拉维夫中央车站里面，我更愿意在其他地方工作。我们可以这样继续下去，相信我。我们从不缺这种录音。2002 年，底层永久关闭。原因：空气污染严重。
Look at my cash register. No money. Come look. You can't make a living here, no work, no nothing. I'm just sitting here passing the time. I prefer to work in another place than inside here in Tel Aviv Central Basis Station. And we can go on like this, believe me. We're not short on this kind of tape. In 2002, the ground floor was closed for good. The reason, excessive air pollution.
这意味着市政公交公司丹（Dan）搬到了六楼和七楼，紧挨着国家公交运营商埃加德（Egged）。因此，现在随着所有站台都位于顶楼，车站的整个概念——即人们在从一辆公交车换乘到另一辆公交车的途中会穿过各家商店——不复存在了。车站的低层变成了幽灵楼层。不久之后，就像他的前任皮尔茨一样，莫迪凯·约纳申请了破产。从那以后，车站陷入了巨额债务。房地产大亨和银行把这个烫手山芋传来传去，店主们在法庭上起诉，而这一切的中心是车站总经理米基·泽夫，他正在竭尽所能地管理这个地方。
That meant that done, the municipal bus company moved up to the sixth and seventh floors, right next to Egget, the national bus carrier. So now, with all the platforms located on the top floors, the entire concept of the station, that people will trickle down through the shops on their way from one bus to the other was gone. The lower floors of the station became ghost floors. And before long, just like his predecessor peels, Molde Chayonna filed for bankruptcy. Since then, the station has fallen deep in debt. There are real estate billionaires and banks passing the hot potatoes from one to the other, store owners suing in court and in the middle of all of this is Miki Zeev, the station's general manager who's doing his
他尝试了各种创新的解决方案，为艺术家提供廉价租金、工作室、文化活动、会议。但看起来车站似乎只是越来越空。我们这里有 1500 家店铺，但只有 600 家开业。因为建筑太大了，它们并不是必需的。起初，规划者认为每天有多达一百万人流经车站。如今，每天只有 5 万人来。
best to run the place. He's tried all kinds of creative solutions, cheap rates for artists, studios, cultural events, conferences. But it seems as if the station is just getting emptier and emptier. We have here 1,500 stores, but only 600 are open. Because the building is so huge, they are not necessary. At first, the planners thought that up to a million people a day would pass through the station. Nowadays, every age 50,000 people are coming.
数字在下降。5 万人，这仅占最初估算的 5%。也许这就是问题的根源。开发商同意让他们出售越来越多的商业空间，这反过来又使车站的规模膨胀到不成比例。或者这一切只是因为地段、地段、地段，把车站建在特拉维夫南部贫困街区注定了它的命运。或者这只是简单的目光短浅。在 20 世纪 60 年代，全以色列只有 2.4 万辆私家车，每个人都使用公共交通。谁当时知道这个数字会增长
It's going down. 50,000 people, that's just 5% of the original estimate. Maybe this is the root of the problem. The developers agreed led them to sell more and more commercial spaces, which in turn blew the station's size out of proportion. Or maybe it's all just location, location, location, and putting the station in the poor neighborhoods of southern Tel Aviv sealed its fate. Or perhaps it was simple short-sightedness. In the 1960s there were only 24,000 private vehicles in all of Israel, and everybody used public transportation. Who knew then that this number would increase
超过一百倍，达到今天拥堵在我们道路上的 250 万辆汽车。当皮尔茨和卡米构思这个项目时，他们想象的是一座屋顶下的城市。当一切尘埃落定后，它确实有点那种氛围。这是建筑师塔莉亚。在某种程度上，它被称为屋顶下的城市，这话说明了一切。在一座城市里，你拥有一切。你拥有黑暗的空间，你拥有明亮的空间，你拥有有趣的部分，你拥有可怕的部分，你拥有令人兴奋的部分。
more than a hundred fold and reach the 2.5 million cars that crowd our roads today. When Pilts and Karmie dreamt up the project, they imagined a city under a roof. And when all said and done, it does kind of have that vibe. Here's Talia, the architect. In a way, the fact that it's called a city under a roof kind of says it all. In a city you've got everything. You've got the dark spaces, you've got the lit spaces, you've got the interesting bits, you have the scary bits, you have the exciting bits.
所有这些都在那里存在着，以某种方式在那里共存。尽管周围一片阴暗，有时你会有一种感觉，你可以在这里度过你的一生。这里有邮局、杂货店、旅行社。你可以找到牙科诊所、律师、教堂、市场、学校、服装店、艺术家工作室、幼儿园。这里还有一颗原子弹避难所和犹太会堂。这里有一个完整的世界，就在特拉维夫的眼皮底下。只是可惜没有人
And all of it just exists there, co-exist there, in a way. Despite the gloominess all around, sometimes you get the feeling you can spend your whole life in here. There's a post office, a grocery shop, travel agencies. You can find a dentist clinic, lawyers, churches, markets, schools, clothes, artists, studios, kindergarten. There's also an atomic bomb shelter and synagogues. There's a whole world in here, right under Tereviw's nose. It's just a shame that nobody
所有这一切就那样存在着，以某种方式共存着。尽管周围一片阴暗，有时你会觉得你可以在这里度过一生。这里有邮局、杂货店、旅行社。你可以找到牙科诊所、律师、教堂、市场、学校、服装店、艺术家工作室、幼儿园。这里还有防空洞和犹太会堂。这里有一个完整的世界，就在泰雷津的眼皮底下。只可惜没有人
bothers to pick up the stone and take a look beneath it. More than 50 years have passed since the idea for the Central Bus Station was born in a creative mind of Arya Peelts and started to take shape on Ram Karmie's drawing board. Ever since, people have been trying to figure out what to do with it. Here's Shon Rodbalt, the architect again. I can certainly see how in the past 10-15 years the use of the station is decreasing, shops are closing, trade is deteriorating and gradually causing deterioration in all the neighborhoods around here. In this case there is no really a winner, everybody's a loser,
费心思去捡起石头看看下面。距离中央汽车站的想法在阿里亚·皮尔茨充满创意的头脑中诞生并开始在拉姆·卡尔米的图纸上成形，已经过去50多年了。从那时起，人们就一直在琢磨该拿它怎么办。再次请出建筑师肖恩·罗德巴尔特。我当然能看到在过去10-15年里，车站的使用率在下降，商店在关门，商业在恶化，并逐渐导致这里所有周边社区的恶化。在这种情况下，没有真正赢家，大家都是输家，
the architect of this building, Ram Karmee has been really despised for this project and it affects ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא עוד קרקטים, ‫הוא ע which means a fool may throw into a well-estone which a hundred wise men cannot pull out. Riftgekarmi, Ram's widow, is a bit more optimistic. I believe the story of the central bastation is not over yet. Pinchas for his part is desperate. And I'm over 80 years old today. They used to be young. I had the will to deal with them. Nowadays, I have no energy.
这座建筑的建筑师拉姆·卡尔米因为这个项目而饱受蔑视，这影响了...这意味着一个愚夫抛进井里的一块石头，一百个智者也捞不起来。拉姆的遗孀里夫卡·卡尔米则要乐观一些。我相信中央汽车站的故事还没有结束。平哈斯则感到绝望。我今天已经80多岁了。他们过去年轻时，我有意愿去对付他们。如今，我没有精力了。
And they're very cool. There are many parallels between the story of the central bus station and the entire Zionist project, entrepreneurship, creating facts on the ground, the patchwork system, gradual move towards privatization and capitalism. In the state's case it worked pretty well, but not so with the central bus station, at least not so far.
而且它们非常酷。中央汽车站的故事与整个犹太复国主义项目、创业精神、在地面上制造既成事实、拼凑系统、逐步走向私有化和资本主义之间有许多相似之处。在国家的情况下，这运作得相当不错，但中央汽车站并非如此，至少目前还不是。
But who knows, maybe the station's good days still lie ahead and the grandchildren of Ilan, Pinchas, Mark, and many more will end up inheriting a shop in the so-ho of Tel Aviv. For now, while history debates whether the new central bus station is a stone thrown by a fool or a spectacular human monument, many people that we would rather forget have turned this strange and confusing place into their home. That's reporter Yohai Metal for Israel Story, with production help from Katie Polverman. It was edited and produced by Yohai Metal, Mishiharman, and Julie Subran. Israel Story is a great new podcast from PRX and Tablet magazine, hosted by Mishiharman, who you heard at the top of the show. A lot of people, including Ira Glass, call it the Israeli This American Life.
但谁知道呢，也许车站的好日子还在后头，伊兰、平哈斯、马克以及许多其他人的孙辈最终会继承特拉维夫Soho区的一家商店。目前，当历史在争论新的中央汽车站是愚人扔出的石头还是壮观的人类纪念碑时，许多我们宁愿忘记的人已经把这个奇怪而令人困惑的地方当成了他们的家。这是“以色列故事”的记者约哈伊·梅塔尔，制作助理是凯蒂·波尔弗曼。它由约哈伊·梅塔尔、米希·哈尔曼和朱莉·苏布兰剪辑和制作。“以色列故事”是PRX和《平板》杂志推出的一档出色的新播客，由你在节目开头听到的米希·哈尔曼主持。许多人，包括伊拉·格拉斯，称它为以色列版的《美国生活》。
They specialize in telling human stories from Jews and Arabs, secular and religious people, from one of the most fascinating places on Earth. You can find all their episodes every place that you get podcasts and on their website, isrealstory.org. 99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan, Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead, Katie Mingle, Avery Troubleman, Shereefusef, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, an architecture and interior sperm. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Instagram, Tumblr, and Spotify,
他们擅长讲述犹太人和阿拉伯人、世俗和宗教人士的人性故事，故事发生在这个地球上最迷人的地方之一。你可以在所有提供播客的地方以及他们的网站isrealstory.org上找到他们的所有单集。“99%隐形”团队包括萨姆·格林斯潘、德兰尼·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁布曼、谢里夫·尤塞夫以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在建筑与室内设计事务所Arxine的办公室制作。地点位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在Twitter、Instagram、Tumblr和Spotify上，
but the best place to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is on our website. It's 99pi.org. Radio Tepi-O from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但探索塑造我们世界设计的“99%隐形”活动的最佳地点是我们的网站。网址是99pi.org。来自PRX的Radio Tepi-O。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。